shadow of war is a dense action RPG with
a lot of skills to unlock systems to get
your head around and of course many many
orcs just right there for the killings
our previous tips video focus on the
opening few hours of the game before you
get the ability to bend Oryx to your
will the dominate ability that you get
at the beginning of the second act is a
complete and utter game-changer pardon
the pun so here's a few more tips for
middle-earth shadow of war including how
to get the most out of its famed Nemesis
system number one worms as soon as you
enter a new region in Mordor your first
port of call should be to purify the
three high deer towers to unlock fast
travel points and earn an easy skill
points from there you should hunt out
the worms that will give you valuable
intel on the enemy captains and
WarChiefs something we noticed was that
worms are actually quicker to dominate
than regular orcs so if you're not up
for a fight or you're in a rush to
collect your Intel and plot your attack
on the WarChiefs you can run in dominate
the worm and be out of there in a flash
number two getting higher level
followers once you recruit a knock to
your army there are various ways to
increase his power level to make him
stronger
before you start recruiting make sure
you have wealth gems attached to your
ring of power if you have these attached
any captain new recruit automatically
gains a couple of levels when they join
your side the more powerful the gem the
more levels your captain gains also if
you've been eyeing up a particular app
that you're looking to recruit have a
worm send them a death threat before you
go after them doing this increases the
level of the captain by five they call
it a dance rate but it's flattering to
be wanted
you have three turns to complete these
missions dying completing other nemesis
missions or skipping time ahead at a
high dere tower it takes up a turn if
you choose to do other missions and
don't fulfill the death threat you can
actually send him another one to
increase his power by a further five
levels once recruited you can start
doing missions to increase your orcs
levels sending them to kill enemy
captain's as long
they succeed NAB's a couple levels for
them but the best way for order to leap
up in levels is to use the fighting pits
if you control a region that is you've
completed its fortress assault and
instilled your own overlord you'll have
access to its fighting pits
you can send orcs to face off against
each other in the pits and the winner
gains a good number of levels so if you
want to bring a low level orc up to
yours the best thing to do is send him
right down to the pits if he loses and
dies just track down the captain that
one and recruit him because you'll still
be benefiting from the levels he earned
because he won number three combat
dominate but the dominate ability can
quickly turn the tide in most combat
scenarios when attacking an outpost for
example target the archers first they
can reign pain down on those below and
are less likely to be taken out by enemy
orcs on the ground but when you're being
attacked by enemies from every single
angle there's an easy way to use
dominate to avoid dying call in a
bodyguard or a Cara Gor and then back
off as long as there's someone friendly
to take the heat you can hold down the
dominate button and turn a bunch of orcs
to your side fairly quickly now while
this is happening the orcs seem to slow
down on attacking you often just
standing by idly if you do see an enemy
approaching you you've actually got
quite a lot of leeway before the counter
prompt appears invest in the combat
dominate skill to turn orcs to your side
even faster number four Marion Marion is
the most important currency not only is
it the one that you actually obtain by
playing the game but it's the one that
you use in game you can use it to buy
the lower quality loot boxes but
honestly don't bother you'll find decent
enough items as you run around killing
captains and you need to spend your
marion on more important things like
unlocking gem slots and on siege
defenses and offenses so here's some
easy ways to make a little extra money
as you kill enemy captains and war
Chiefs you'll pick up better and better
pieces of gear don't let your old items
clog up the inventory instead
deconstruct them for Mirian now items
that belong to legendary armor sets
can't be deconstructed nor can epic or
rare items that you've upgraded but
purple drops from legendary orcs can be
dismantled for a substantial amount as
you walk through Mordor you'll come
across these orcs with the white symbol
above their heads signalling that their
treasure carriers make sure to kill them
for some easy Mirian if you're running
low
make sure you've attached wealth gems to
all three of your weapons as these gems
increase the chance that enemies drop
Marian when they die more powerful
wealth gems means a higher chance of a
money drop and finally orcs now belong
to tribes and the tribe of the region's
overlord affect the whole area once you
take over a region and put a new
Overlord in charge his tribe will give
different bonuses so if you need some
extra money
make sure your overlord is a member of
the Marauder tribe these guys love
treasure so they'll leave Marian chests
full of money all around the region for
you to find and loot number 5 the
Nemesis system where shadow of war
really shines is the Nemesis system it's
a dynamic system where the enemy
hierarchy constantly shifts and adjusts
but it's one that also can be completely
manipulated by you orcs constantly
battle each other for power so there are
always openings coming up for your guys
to take up first of all I mentioned it
earlier but remember that these missions
are only active for a limited time after
three turns they get resolved and the
orc that wins encounter increases in
level it's also worth remembering that
unless you directly interfere with these
missions they might not work out in your
armies
if you see one of your followers
embroiled in a nemesis mission you can
send another follower as backup raising
your guys chance of success you can
always pop along too if you want to
dominate the enemy captain instead of
having him die if you get killed by an
enemy orc or even betrayed by one of
your own this happens and it's
devastating you can go get your revenge
choose the vendetta mission and if you
kill whoever took you down you'll get
some better quality loot but easily the
most fun nemesis encounters are betrayal
missions use Intel to determine who a
war Chiefs bodyguards are recruit them
to your side and you can set up an
ambush to take out the war chief by
killing or recruiting the war chief to
your side it disables their associated
defenses at the fortress assaults pretty
much making it a cakewalk number 6
online fortress assaults once you've
taken a fortress in the single-player
don't forget to defend it because it can
be attacked online but ensuring that
it's defended well is an easy way to
earn spoils of war a loot chest that's
guaranteed to contain at least one
legendary follower in the army menu tap
r1 or right bumper to bring up the siege
upgrade menu make sure you have
followers assigned in every open slot
and marién levels permitting the
strongest defenses in place for an extra
bit of Defense assigned bodyguards to
your war Chiefs when the fortress gets
attacked either online or in the game's
defense missions they can help hold on
to defense points for longer by ensuring
that every war chief is in position
there are defenses and there are
bodyguards it increases your defense
rating in online ranked conquests
there's also an attack rating buts based
on how well you attack others fortresses
by participating in online assaults
these ratings increase allowing you to
rank up higher ranks provide a
percentage bonus unspoiled of war gained
from online activities which means the
more you play online the more spoils of
war you get which means more goodies you
get at the end lovely stuff
number seven advanced skills to invest
in over the course of the game you'll
easily earn enough skill points to
unlock all italians abilities but here
the ones that you should prioritize if
you find it mega annoying to have to
hold r1 or right bumper to pick up an
item then treasure hunter allows you to
pick up items just by walking over them
why this is an unlockable skill I have
no idea but it's worth getting as soon
as you can if you want to become one
with the beasts pickup hack master
Shadow Man sing a Kerrigan eights all of
the nearby ones too as long as they
don't have a rider on them meaning that
you'll be leader of the pack in no time
shadow strike is another skill that
takes a weirdly long time to unlock but
once you have it invest in its upgrade
chain of Shadows not only is it one of
the coolest looking skills but it's mega
useful for dropping in on a group of
enemies unannounced and taking them out
one by one and finally Dragon song
complete the qanun quests to be able to
summon in a Drake unlock dragon rider to
basically go full daenerys targaryen on
anyone that dares to stand in your way
so there we are some more tips for
middle-earth shadow of war if you have
any of your own leave them in the
comments box below for more on the game
including our review make sure to keep
your eyes peeled to GameSpot